all right
stacy yes stacy where are you from
originally where'd you grow up i grew up
in
north carolina in a small town called
asheboro
but i really was i mean i was raised in
the woods
all i did was so this is uh western
north carolina
uh no like the middle center
yeah you know where the zoo is i don't
okay well that's where it's at
cool and tell me about your childhood
you grew up with both your parents
uh no not well until i was about two i
had both my parents but they
fought so much that um they ended up
drawing guns on each other
and my mom left my dad so i was raised
by my mom
single parent household i'm mixed i'm
half black half white
raised in the south and i tell people
it's like
it's one thing being white and it's one
thing being black it's another thing
being mixed it's like you're just caught
in the middle and you have no
you just don't know which way you're
going to go at any given point
which one do you relate to more um
probably my white side just because i
was raised by
my mom who is white yeah and how was
your childhood
um i mean i thought it was okay but i
normalized what was going on my mom
drank i mean she was a binge drinker and
she
would sometimes pass out and i'd have to
take care of my little sister and
brother and
nurse her back to health when she had
hangovers and
we would go to jute joints and i mean
it was just i mean to me it was normal
but it wasn't normal
but no views um yes i got
molested when i was i don't know
eight or nine my neighbor was an old man
my mom was drunk um i don't remember if
when she was drunk or
she just we just went over there and
he told me he'd give me money if i let
him touch me so
i did so
that going a long time um a few months
until i finally told somebody
and what happened to him nothing nothing
common story
and then what age were you when you left
home
i started running away when i was 14 i
left when i was 16.
moved out i'm all when i was 16 but um
i went from being in the country to go
into the city and it was the fast life
then i got
mesmerized by it and chased it that was
it where'd you go
uh just in the city part of asheboro i
lived on the outskirts that's where i
grew up yeah
so um the first time i got there
when we first moved there all the lights
were on all night long you know like
street lights we didn't have that in the
country if you went
home by like 5 30 or 6 in the evening
you were stuck out in the dark
so that was different and great
and what were you doing for how are you
surviving
um i worked and i
prostituted myself really
and were drugs in the picture then
which drugs are used by that time
cocaine crack marijuana
and alcohol
so do you have kids of your own now i
have one did you raise
she's with my mom i did for like the
first three years of her life and
then i just keep going in and out of
doing really good and then doing really
bad and
i don't know it's like i have to tear
myself down just to build myself up
like i've had homes and cars and really
good jobs i've went to school
i'm a nurse but
i just can't seem to stay away from the
gutter what is it
you think that keeps taking you down
myself my thoughts about myself
is it like your self-worth you just
think you belong
down here it seems to be easier for me
to build myself
up when i'm down here if i'm at the top
with people
i don't feel like i fit in i feel like
an imposter
yeah but i know that
i mean i want to believe that i'm good
enough to be there because
i can perform but it's my mind that
tells me that yeah
that i'm not good enough that they
really don't like me
that i don't even know why i'm doing
this because it's all gonna
end up being a disaster anyway and then
i
end up making it a disaster what do you
think that stems from is it is it your
parenting
is it your brain chemistry is it your um
i think it stems from a lot of things um
i mean you were touching on it my
parenting
i have mental health disorders just
not really coping healthy healthy and
then being introduced to drugs i mean
once that
comes it's like
it's the hardest thing i've ever had to
do is stop
do you think being molested at eight
years old may have
kind of planted that seed of
low self-worth yeah i think that that
has something to do with it
and you know something to do with me
prostituting myself too because like i
said he offered me money to touch my
boobs
and
so where are you staying now you're
you're i was staying in the van with my
boyfriend but
we got i don't know fight last night and
i don't know where i'm staying now i'll
probably
end up going back home and where's back
home north carolina oh yeah
you go back north carolina yeah i don't
want to stay here and be trapped here
your daughter's back there she's wet
your daughter's back there right
yeah so are my parents my whole family's
there
how old was your daughter she's seven
i'm sure she'd be happy to see you
yeah have you been clean before
yep a couple a few times
so your drug today is what today
yeah um i've been smoking crack
have you tried some other drugs have i
tried another truck yeah
yeah i'm not really my thing
it's the crack that keeps pulling me
down
and what you've been doing for money
what have you been doing for money out
here i have a job
i actually am an admissions coordinator
i get people into treatment
so
interesting huh yeah
do you still do you stay in contact with
your daughter and your mom
yeah so yeah i call a facetime or a
video chat on
sometimes a a tough break like what
happened last night for you
actually could be a good thing in the
long run
i hope something good starts happening
yeah i think i think you're tired
looking at your
self sabotaging
behavior is is the key to a lot of the
stuff
because i keep hearing the same story
over and over again that people believe
they deserve this they
think they belong down here and clearly
nobody belongs down here
all right well thank you so much for
talking to me you're welcome
i'm sorry i'm yeah i know it's been a
rough night for you
yes
well good luck with everything i hope
you get to see your daughter thank you
thank you
you